welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and the batman starring robert
pattinson released an
official trailer proving that you can go
from emaciated vampire to eviscerating
vengeance
director matt reeves has only shot like
25 to 30
of this film and yet this trailer was so
damn good
i just had to barf out an immediate
reaction video but now we're gonna get
into what new rockstars does best
because
like batman i too see the world as a
crime scene filled with clues and visual
details
only decipherable with an overactive
imagination and an appreciation for
psycho research walls and in my pursuit
folks
i actually solved riddler's first riddle
i'm gonna decode it for you and the
secrets behind why this nirvana song was
chosen in this frame by frame breakdown
of everything you overlooked in this
batman trailer
and my predictions for where this
movie's going spoiler warning in case
any of my sleuthing reveals too much
honestly it might
let's get started
we open on a grisly murder a victim's
head taped up with the words
no more lies written on it i love how
these opening warner and dc titles
stagger the way duct tape does when you
peel it off the roll
warner brings you hope for the future
but i gotta say this
is what we call overkill like speaking
from personal experience you use maybe
one or two pieces of tape if you want to
shut up your captive in this case the
killer saw
the guy's whole face as a lie that
needed to be stifled
the killer edward nashton paul dano this
movie's the riddler
his green coat and green envelope are
about as fanservicey as we're gonna get
because this guy seems more inspired by
serial killers in david fincher's more
films
like john doe and seven were the zodiac
who of course was also a real life guy
who could still be out there nah now
we're pretty sure who it is it's me
there's this chilling sound of a breath
sucked through a mask
[Music]
but notice how the victim's duct tape
doesn't move near his mouth this guy is
dead so this is the breath of the killer
through
his duct tape mask wheezing after
exerting himself to kill this man
let's keep sleuthing
from your secret friend who we followed
jim gordon jeffrey right into the crime
scene but notice the apprehensive
glances from the other cops on the way
in
looking at us they're sizing up the
figure following gordon
batman putting us the audience in the
boots of the world's greatest detective
trying to decode this scene
game on now reeves said this would be a
year 2 batman not an origin story but
also not an older grizzled dark knight
returns batman meanwhile there is a
spin-off series in the works following
gordon's work with the gotham pd
that will be a year 1 prequel showing
how gordon overcame pressure from these
corrupt cops
to forge this alliance with batman it
was just announced that young actor
barry cogan is playing a role in the
film
now the victim's hand is covered by a
paper bag
back in that first shot he did have
something on his left hand maybe a ring
maybe a ring telling his involvement
with some other shady enterprises one
that the killer had to get by maybe
cutting off the finger
now we gotta talk about the music here
nirvana's something in the way
it echoes the grunge lonely aspects of
this version of bruce wayne who does in
a way trap animals and struggles to
empathize with them
but there are two deeper layers of
subtext to the song that make it an even
creepier choice
see kurt cobain claimed the lyrics were
about a time he'd sleep under a bridge
but later biographers revealed that that
river tide would have been too high for
him to sleep
under that bridge and that cobain was
probably crashing at his friend's houses
so really this song is about cobain's
inner loneliness
how he weirdly wishes he was homeless
because yeah that's kind of how
depression works
you judge yourself for feeling the way
you feel and in a weird way
wish that your circumstances were even
worse than they are similarly this is
how bruce's mind is
he has every resource to live
comfortably he has a home with alfred
but yet
he still chooses to be a loner in the
night rain but here's even deeper reason
see something in the way is the final
listed track on the never mind album but
in most pressings the song's moody
acoustic chords
fade into silence and then you wait 10
full minutes of silence
until a secret track comes out of
nowhere endless nameless
it's a violent outburst that really
scares the hell out of you if you don't
know what's coming
[Music]
so you think something in the way refers
to something in the way of the loner
lifestyle but the song itself
is literally that something in the way
of how cobain was really feeling inside
just like how this batman seeks a secret
that you have to wait through an
endless void to get to and then it hits
you with sudden violence
violence that really comes from within
your own soul reeves said that a big
influence on his story was darwin cook's
batman ego comic which dives into
batman's psychology and the union
archetypes that inspire the different
pieces of his broken identity but anyway
back to the crime scene
having a clue
let's play a game just me and you yes
crazy newspaper wall let's look at it
okay the gotham times the gothic gazette
report about mayor don
mitchell jr winning a historic third
term
defeating opponent bella rayal who in
this movie is played by jamie lawson so
that likely makes this victim
gotham city's mayor explaining why fbi
agents would be on the scene
lies written over at all suggest that
mitchell's election might have been
rigged or believed to be and that
riddler could be trying to expose that
conspiracy so we get the big clue here
riddler's green envelope containing this
card
from your secret friend who haven't a
clue
let's play a game just me and you the
[ __ ]
kind of card is this who gives halloween
cards
why is a skeleton friends with an owl
yeah you wouldn't buy
this off a stand this must have been
custom printed by the killer
and probably something much more than
just a vague reference to the long
halloween comic issue that everyone says
this movie's gonna be based on the owl i
believe is a clue pointing to the court
of
owls the shadowy cult that runs gotham
city recently revealed as the villains
in the gotham knights game
who i believe could be behind this
conspiracy that riddler is trying to
expose
with many secret friends who are now
skeletons in their closets more on this
later because more importantly the
handwritten message reads what does a
liar do when he's dead
and then on the other side a zodiac
style string of glyphs
that i have decoded so let's code break
this in okay the first thing you always
look for is repeating symbols so the
third symbol shows up twice at the end
so it must be the same letter right
also the second and the fifth are the
same letter the fourth and the ninth are
the same letter and the sixth and the
seventh are the same letter so a double
letter at the end makes it a bit easy
does that mean it's probably a consonant
s maybe l and that would mean the letter
before it is a vowel so you can apply
this wheel of fortune scrabble type
thinking working backwards that way
while you look at the broader context
the cover of the card is a pun
the owl says who so it follows that the
answer to riddler's question would also
be a joke
so what does the liar do when he's dead
he lies
still yep pretty brilliant word play
that tells us something about the
riddler
he sees a liar like the mayor as still
capable of embodying a lie in his death
and as we go through we'll talk about
how this riddle answer will affect the
rest of the story on to the next part
any of this mean anything to you
okay framed on the mayor's wall is the
headline moroni drug bust
mirrors the sting operation historic so
in the dc comics the maroneys are one of
gotham's crime families with salmoroni
the guy who burned harvey dent's face
with acid
the maroneys are rivals to the falcones
with john tuturo playing carmine falcone
in this movie now i'll say this it's a
bit odd for a
mayor to get the media credit for an
organized crime bus normally that's a
d.a or police commissioner kind of win
so i'm thinking that the falcones could
have helped the mayor win re-election
from an alliance in which the mayor took
down their rivals the maroons okay we
see our batman here he's got a chest
emblem that looks like it's made up of
two removable weapons maybe batarangs
maybe blades
and the handles of them look like they
could be the split shaft of a handgun
handle one theory being that this could
be the gun that joe chile used to kill
his parents
now he uses it as a reminder never to
kill just slice through people's necks
and cave their skulls in
i'm vengeance and i love how he's
introduced with the photographer's
camera recharge
sound on the flash thxc
expressing batman's disgust that a
killer trying to get his attention is
what caused all this
it's my fault that's why those cops gave
me the side eye vengeance
the truth is it's a bit tough knowing
what the right answer is just like when
you're shopping online and there's that
blinking cursor
on the promo code field and you just
don't know if there's an answer out
there that you should plug something in
feel like you're missing out on great
deals well thanks to honey promo code
fomo code is a thing of the past
honey is the free browser extension that
automatically finds promo codes and
applies them to your cart
so if you're shopping online at target
or gamestop domino's wherever
when you check out a little box drops
down and all you have to do is click
apply coupons you wait a few seconds for
it to scan
promo codes from across the internet and
you watch the prices drop
like not too long ago i was shopping for
an herb garden planner for my little
patio space and i found one
on target.com honey saved me over 10
bucks i was going to buy that planner
anyways but now i have a place for like
bugs and nuts to grow civilizations on
while i watch my plants die and an extra
10
new rockstars fans that have already
downloaded honey in the past using our
promo code have already saved themselves
almost
three hundred thousand dollars can i get
any of that
no i can't because it's in your wallets
and don't you want to be one of those
lucky people
honey supports over 30 000 stores online
including walmart j crew new egg
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
money it's literally free and installs
in just a few seconds and by getting it
you'll be doing yourself a solid and
supporting new rock stars get honey for
free at joinhoney.comrockstars that's
joinhoney.com
new rockstars let's move on with the
rest of the trailer
[Music]
you're becoming quite a celebrity
okay there's a press conference with
actor alex burns we believe playing
police commissioner pete
savage who savage's right is actor khan
o'neal both played roles in hbo's
chernobyl
o'neil played the cowardly local
official ferns played a heroic miner who
uh stripped down to nothing i don't know
just worth pointing out because you can
imagine maybe they were cast because
those characters had certain values that
they play really well and that they'll
use in this movie but we cut to a bit
wider bruce's external point of view on
this press conference where we can see a
very shaken gordon
and most likely the victim's grieving
wife we see bruce's covered face showing
black eye makeup around the eyes
something that batman
would need to hide his identity under
the cowl and something that past batman
iterations tend to shy away from but i'm
so glad they're sticking to it here
bruce rides his bike through the
cemetery that we saw in set videos and
then
rolls up into the bat cave now this face
is cavernous and then a ramp leads
up into it it's got two huge stairs and
an overhang that if you look closely
reads
wayne terminal i want to say because
maybe this is an abandoned subway
station
with bruce being able to use this grid
to navigate gotham underground pop up
wherever he needs to now why would a
city's public transportation network be
abandoned well it happens all the time
just look at my hometown jacksonville
florida's skyway
i once used it to fight crime over seven
stops one of those stops being between
stops
i'm just saying it's hard to be
jacksonville's batman when a firefighter
has to cradle you down to safety but
actually there might be a story here
because look at those moisture stains on
the walls of the bat cave
back in that crazy newspaper wall was
another headline reading seawall
construction stalled
now matt reeves cited chinatown as an
influence on this mystery plot chinatown
is about
la's water wars in the 1930s the
corruption behind
urban irrigation and drainage so it
sounds like this could be an issue in
gotham too
battles that were maybe resolved by the
subway lines being flooded
that way bruce could secretly later
drain some of them for his personal use
we hear andy circus says alfred
cautioning bruce on his rising celebrity
status something i assume that this year
too bruce doesn't really want yet
on to the next part
[Music]
why is he writing to you mayor
mitchell's funeral gets crashed
literally only bruce stays in the line
of danger to save a kid
i'm guessing this could be the mayor's
son because i think the mom there was
the woman outside the house
really anytime batman meets a kid the
robin speculation begins and i did
suggest some dark theories about how a
dick grayson could tie into the story in
my other video go check that out now the
car appears to be tagged with the
letters d-o-a
maybe for dead on arrival the later
overhead shot shows it's also marked
with a riddler question mark
with duct tape section it off in the
letterboxes so i'm thinking the next
clue in this mystery could be the car
itself but the driver of this car
is also a victim he is taped up and he
has a neck bomb
the yellow clue with a phone taped to
his hand and i'm thinking the voice of
the riddler that we hear later in this
trailer is coming through this phone
if you are justice please
do not lie actually kind of similar to
the way the dark knight joker rigged
people with explosives also the way he
targeted a past victim's funeral to make
his next move
hbo's watchman also kind of did this but
all of this could be foretold by that
he lies still clue because it tells us
that the riddler does not plan to let
the mayor get buried peacefully
if his eulogies are still just gonna be
lies about his legacy
moving on
if you are justice
please do not lie okay here we meet our
selena kyle zoe kravitz not yet formerly
cat woman according matt reeves but a
cat burglar sneaking into the crime
scene and breaking into the mayor's safe
batman later confronts her so i'm
thinking she must be connected to the
skeletons in the mayor's closet neither
plans to expose them or maybe make sure
no one finds them and then some deal is
going down outside the city of gotham
sanitation east side depot
and we know from tv that all characters
who work in sanitation are really
sanitizing and moving bodies
and indeed later this deal appears to
end in a shootout then in the rain there
is who we are being told is this movie's
oswald cobblepot penguin
though i gotta say this doesn't look
anything like colin farrell i know the
actor gained some weight but he is
unrecognizable they must have put on a
ton of prosthetics they definitely
hooked out his nose and plumped out his
chin
and if you look closely you can see they
definitely added a scar running from his
cheek to
right below his nose and reeves
confirmed in the panel that oz
as we're calling him isn't yet the
penguin boss yet and in fact he doesn't
like being called the penguin and then
we see this gang with white skull
makeup crosses extended skeleton like
smiles kind of reminds me weirdly of
that street gang for batman forever
some are saying the white face makeup
could be a connection to the joker but
honestly i hope not
we have seen plenty of the joker can we
please take a break from the joker i
love the character there's just so many
other rogues gallery people we need to
explore like rinder like quarter vowels
you get a quick shot of bruce working
with the suit and his cowl in this red
lit space kind of like that initial
screen test i'm actually thinking since
reeves was only working with limited
footage from the movie that he shot so
far that they might have mixed in some
that early test footage close-ups of the
suit in this trailer
then batman scuffles with the gcpd
gordon has to hold him back
very interesting example of the hostile
rivalry between these authorities
on to the next part what is the price
for
your blind eye okay during batman's
fight with selena kyle she wears a ski
mask with pointed corners for the cat
ears the mask does pretty little to
cover her face it's really just her nose
and cheeks why cover only those parts
maybe
because she has a distinguishing scar on
the same place that
oswald copperbot does then we see the
neckbomb victim actually
detonates yikes it blows batman off his
feet you can see they tried to use a
bomb defusing robot to take care of it
but nashton probably would have demanded
the batman and the voice of nashton asks
what is
the price for your blind
body suggesting a kind of reckoning for
batman and the police for overlooking
corruption in their own city but the key
word there is
blind as in blind as a bat maybe a
reference to that final riddle in batman
forever
you're as blind as a bat when it comes
to riddlers we've come a long way my
friends
[Music]
but yeah here blind is clearly a dig at
batman for being too focused on
nighttime crime
that in the broad daylight he is blind
to the crimes committed by city leaders
next the hell are you supposed to be
yeah you are the combat here is brutal
batman blocks the machete blow you'll
notice his gauntlets are lined with
quills
some are saying similar to the dc
vigilante talon who works with the court
of owls but yeah during the fight you
can definitely hear the guy's jaw
break when batman hits him in the face
and then even after the ko he hits him
twice more they're so intense that i
love this the reaction by the other gang
members one of them clearly has
tears in his eyes from the fear and
right when we assume batman's gonna say
i'm batman i'm batman i'm batman good
afternoon mr glee
i'm batman we instead get this great
mystery
i'm vengeance but this isn't random it
actually echoes the classic
three-line phrase from the nothing to
fear episode of the animated series i
am vengeance i am the knight
i am batman almost like matt reeves
knows that for many of us the truest
batman is the voice of kevin conroy
and i do hope that this batman says all
three parts of that phrase throughout
this movie maybe i
am vengeance against the street gang
then i am the knight against riddler or
penguin and then the final
i am batman against the true villains
but more on those in a bit let's move on
we get some six shots of this movie's
new batmobile which is a muscle car
with an exposed engine that burns blue
so you know it's hot
it smashes through a pipeline in the
pursuit of oz and then batman takes a
few gunshots
one the chest from the gang and he
recoils on the impact and it looks like
it ricochets the bullet to the thug
behind him and then the shot of batman
slinging up a stairwell past
cops cops who fire at him yeah the
hostilities are gonna get pretty intense
and then finally the red
title notice how it briefly gives the
second a in the word
batman cowl as it forms together and
then inside the word is the bat chest
emblem where you can see the points
where
it latches onto the chest armor maybe
those are hinge points where the blades
could
retract like pocket knives which i have
demonstrated via
arts and crafts i'm very proud of my
work and then the final bit you're
part of this too
oh my part of it
you'll see so in the batcave bruce
removes a cow as he watches a video
on this screen it's hard to tell but it
looks like the figure talks and then
some text lays over them as it shifts to
black and white now i want to say this
could be bella rayal
the mayor's rival because this looks
kind of like the editing of a political
ad
can you really trust this person paid
for by the committee to re-elect don
mitchell jr it could also be a video
riddle of the riddler's next target but
i don't know this riddler seems more
into duct tape and flesh clues than you
know ones made in imovie but the
exchange between bruce and nation is the
interesting part
implying that bruce himself is part of
this murder conspiracy
matt reeves said that this batman will
show a younger dark knights failed
criminological experiment in the city
that results in a mystery that
implicates his
own family's role in the city's history
of corruption i have a feeling that
we're going to learn a lot more about
thomas and martha wayne's possible
involvement
in the court of owl's cabal of elites in
the city of gotham
a conspiracy that could connect the
recently murdered mayor the criminal
organizations of the city
and the true source of the rot in gotham
that nashton is trying to expose and
that batman will have to rip out the
rocks
the court of owls in the next movie look
we're going to continue talking about
this movie and doing deep dives into all
the biggest news coming out of dc fandom
our breakdown of that snyder cut trailer
is coming next on the channel and to see
our coverage right away when it comes
out be sure to subscribe to new
rockstars and hit that notification bell
and for our more personal takes on all
this stuff new rockstars has an
awesome discord community for our
patrons of all tiers even one buck a
month
just go to patreon.com newrockstars you
can follow me on
instagram at eavos follow new rockstars
and be thankful this trailer actually
edited down batman's real beatdown
he's already
[Music]
you